e aí
um beijo 2012 a onu realiza pesquisas
anuais acerca da felicidade das pessoas
por países e pelo segundo ano
consecutivo a finlândia é o país mais
feliz do mundo o brasil ocupa o 32º
lugar nesse ranking até aí tudo bem mas
duas informações acerca dessa mesma
pesquisa realmente me preocupam a
primeira é que nós temos as maiores
taxas de transtornos de ansiedade do
mundo e a segunda é que o brasil é o
país mais depressivo da américa latina
porque estamos tão infelizes e
e em 2018 eu fui convidada para projetar
um espaço que simulasse os ambientes
básicos de uma residência dentro de uma
instituição de ensino para deficientes
físicos e mentais era uma pai é
e esse projeto tinha como objetivo
desenvolver as habilidades desenvolver a
autonomia desses alunos em atividades
mais básicas do seu dia a dia como por
exemplo arrumar sua própria cama se
servir se alimentar sozinho e até mesmo
usar o banheiro de forma independente
e esse projeto foi uma ação social entre
a cooperativa dos cafeicultores local eu
e toda a comunidade envolvida eu me
lembro de ter passado dias dentro dessa
instituição conhecendo os alunos os
colaboradores dessa escola entendendo
essa metodologia de ensino e com uma
verba limitadíssima fruto de uma rifa
nós criamos e executamos esse espaço é
e no dia da inauguração os alunos e os
colaboradores entravam e saíam desses
passos se identificando planejando que
eles iam fazer lá dentro parecia que
automaticamente eles criaram o senso de
pertencimento
nós estávamos ali reunidos as
autoridades locais a mídia local e nós
não estávamos ali para falar do meu
trabalho e nem para ir nobrecer nenhuma
ação em particular estávamos ali
reunidos para falar sobre o potencial
que pessoas e organizações têm para
transformar realidades e
e nesse momento eu comecei a questionar
o real impacto que o meu trabalho tinha
a nível de sociedade a nível de
desenvolvimento humano e até o momento
olhando para trás esse impacto me
parecia muito pequeno eu passei então a
desejar sentir aquela realização que eu
tava sentindo naquele dia e eu sabia que
para isso eu precisava impactar de
verdade o futuro das pessoas
em pouco tempo depois eu comecei a
estudar neuro arquitetura é um tem
amanhã ainda muito novo que está sendo
estudado em diversos países mas
basicamente neuroarquitetura é arte
ciência andando juntas na busca por
criar experiências que melhorem a vida
das pessoas
é mas como assim experiências né eu
tenho certeza que vocês já
experimentaram aqui entrar em um
ambiente pela primeira vez e já senti em
casa senti que poderia passar horas do
seu dia ali dentro ou contrário já
entrou em um ambiente familiar mas
sentiu que já entrou pensando em sair e
não entendeu muito bem o porquê dessa
sensação desagradável a neuropediatra
explica que essas sensações ocorrem
porque nós interpretamos um meio através
dos nossos cinco sentidos então visão
olfato tato paladar e audição esses são
os nossos cinco veículos de comunicação
com tudo que é físico nesse mundo
e o nosso organismo ele funciona como um
relógio o relógio biológico que nos
conecta com os ciclos básicos da
natureza mais especificamente com as 24
horas que nós chamamos de dia acende a
luz do sol nasce o nosso corpo percebe
essa luz através dos nossos olhos e
através da temperatura da nossa pele e
essa primeira percepção esse primeiro
contato funciona como um convite ao
nosso corpo para ele se despertar e
começar a produzir substâncias
importantes ao bom funcionamento do
nosso corpo no decorrer das próximas 24
horas desse dia
é um exemplo dessas substâncias
importantes para o bom funcionamento do
nosso corpo são dois hormônios o
cortisol ea melatonina hormônios
conhecidos como reguladores de níveis
des prés reguladores do nosso mor do
nosso da nossa percepção de bem-estar e
da qualidade do nosso sono então um
exemplo simples de como o ambiente pode
nos modificar fisiologicamente é
ambientes com tons naturais tons e
texturas presentes na natureza com uma
madeira o tijolo de barro com a presença
da luz natural com a presença de plantas
tem o poder de reduzir os nossos níveis
de cortisol e consequentemente os nossos
níveis de stress e levar os nossos
níveis de melatonina e com
oi gente melhorar o nosso amor a nossa
sensação de bem-estar melhorar a nossa
qualidade do sono
bom então investigando com o ambiente
impacta o nosso cérebro um parceria com
outros profissionais de outras áreas
como médicos psicólogos neurocientistas
eu pensei como projetista de ambientes
eu tenho a obrigação então de projetar
esses ambientes de forma estratégica e
empática assim como eu havia feito um lá
no projeto para pai só que ainda sem
entender toda a complexidade envolvida e
para começar a projetar de forma
estratégica eu comecei a investigar a
nossa rotina e comecei por mim mesma
eu fiz um cálculo bem simples
basicamente sobre o meu cerca de oito
horas por dia trabalho cerca de oito
horas por dia e as outras 8 horas eu tô
fazendo o que eu chamo de viabilizando o
meu trabalho eu tô estudando como
melhorar a minha atuação eu estou me
especializando e eu tô me vai chegando
formas de fazer cada vez melhor o meu
trabalho ou seja eu percebi que eu
passava muito mais horas do meu dia em
ambientes relacionado ao meu trabalho do
que na minha própria casa com a minha
própria família
oi e essa não é uma realidade só minha
essa é uma realidade da maioria dos
brasileiros
bom então eu resolvi me especializar em
projectos de ambiente de trabalho com
uma forma de potencializar a minha
atuação e de realmente impactar a vida
das pessoas
é bom e nesse processo eu tive que
repensar toda a minha metodologia de
projeto porque já não fazia mais sentido
iniciar o meu trabalho através do
levantamento do entorno do levantamento
das infraestruturas não fazia mais
sentido iniciar o meu trabalho através
do levantamento métrico e já
principalmente não fazia mais sentido e
esse a ou executar o meu trabalho sem a
participação efetiva do usuário daquele
ambiente então eu adotei a metodologia
chamada uma center design que como o
próprio nome já diz tem o ser humano
como centro centro do designer que que
significa isso significa que é uma
metodologia pautada na experiência do
usuário uma metodologia muito utilizada
por empresas de tecnologia para
e serviços ou produtos
oi e essa nela de metodologia ela nos
orienta a projetar em três etapas a
primeira é ouvir a segunda é criar e a
terceira implementar e eu pensei criar e
implementar é a especialidade de todo
afeto pelo menos deve ser o real
diferencial dessa metodologia é ouvir
mas houve no sentido de fazer uma
imersão na rotina no universo dessa
pessoa então hoje o que eu faço quando
eu entro em uma organização eu inicio a
minha investigação
é através de uma conversa com cada um de
dentro e eu vou entender o que quais são
as características daquela pessoa que
fazem dela um ser único e começa a
investigar essa pessoa é homem ea mulher
como ela se define ela tem necessidades
especiais ou não ela tem alguma alergia
tudo isso é importante essa pessoa
trabalha a próximo ao trabalho dela e
vai de patinete ou ela trabalha longe
demora duas três horas para chegar no
trabalho já chega cansada e estressada
e depois eu faço uma investigação acerca
das atividades dessa pessoa quais são as
atividades que ela prática no dia a dia
ela trabalha mais com computador ou mais
com papéis ela trabalha de pé trabalha
sentada qual a rotina dela ela faz
reuniões durante o dia com quantas
pessoas e depois eu vou investigar nessa
dinâmica da pessoa no ambiente de
trabalho quanto ela se relaciona e com
qual o fluxo com outras pessoas com a
liderança com clientes com parceiros ou
seja eu faço a investigação do indivíduo
a para chegar na cultura organizacional
e só quando eu entendo essa cultura
organizacional é que o parto para criar
experiências mais saudáveis e
experiências inovadoras para essas
pessoas é
é mas vocês devem estar se perguntando o
que que é finlândia seu país mais feliz
do mundo tem a ver com isso tudo que eu
tô falando em 2014 uma empresa
finlandesa que produzem mobiliário
corporativo já vinha realizando
pesquisas acerca da qualidade de vida no
trabalho e ela resolveu reformular toda
a sua sede da empresa pautada na
metodologia com foco na experiência do
usuário e dois anos depois ela realizou
uma pesquisa interna de pós-ocupação e
os resultados foram 68 por cento dos
colaboradores afirmavam que o bem estar
naquele ambiente aumentou setenta e dois
por cento dos colaboradores afirmavam
que produziam com maior qualidade com
mais criatividade e oitenta e nove
porcento dos colaboradores
o que trabalhavam com mais foco ou seja
já em 2016 com as tínhamos uma empresa
líder de mercado finlandesa que tinha um
impacto significativo na vida do
trabalhador com pessoas mais felizes e
mais saudáveis o que faz todo sentido
ela levar esse título de país mais feliz
do mundo
ah mas então
e quer dizer que neuro arquitetura e
ambientes planejados com foco na
experiência do usuário é um privilégio
só de grandes organizações de grandes
empresas não porque neuroarquitetura
nada mais é do que ambientes humanizados
e ambientes humanizados são aqueles que
levam em consideração as suas
características físicas e psicológicas
que te fazem lembrar que você faz parte
de uma natureza então que você precisa
dela tanto quanto ela precisa de você e
que te fazem lembrar que a relação entre
nós seres humanos e o espaço físico
construído deve ser uma relação
harmônica e benéfica ao desenvolvimento
da nossa espécie
e o brasil tá sendo citado como
referência em congressos internacionais
na área de desenvolvimento de pesquisas
neurocientíficas aplicadas a arquitetura
e em muitos desses trabalhos dessas
pesquisas estão sendo realizadas nesse
momento de forma voluntária entre
profissionais da área da construção
civil artistas médicos psicólogos
neurocientistas nós não somos o país
mais feliz do mundo mas à medida que
transformamos profissões em uma forma de
praticar empatia compaixão e amor ao
próximo estamos passo a passo
construindo uma sociedade mais humana
obrigada tá
e aí